how are you so do you you sounded
amazing out there how was it just saying
with JD and just to be out there I
really was hoping you'd say yes because
I've never really sang it with a boy
like that and I was so proud of him yeah
it was emotional whether it really every
time you sing a wicked song I imagine
some sort of emotion comes flooding up
is that true yeah October if it's not
try were sixteen years and that was only
16 when we did it so it's just crazy to
me that it's been going on that long and
people still love it you know movies
coming out 2021 I know I'm like who's
gonna be in it
Ariana Grande and Doug Cameron they
better be it's funny you say that
because Dov told me that she would be so
honored and that you are such a legend
and an icon she had nothing but nice
things to say why do you think she would
be the perfect Glinda the role of Glinda
requires a wide vocal range she's got
that it is the big a big arc in the show
that she starts out blend of the bed and
becomes it's what makes her good you see
that and she's got the acting chops to
do it and you know she's my baby if I
had had a child it would be done look so
much alike - it's crazy I mean I played
her mother twice and there's a reason
and I just see great things for her I
think great things for you because you
have a new album coming out for the
girls miss Dolly Parton on the album
how'd you get that collar up and she was
by me what you think and I was thinking
of one did you hear you coming in that's
not here you can look shows why don't we
do us on I wrote and then she gave I
will always love you which I
I believe that's my fee premier club I
know thank you
I listen to it today again and I would
like I'm emotional right now
thank you I wanted to just celebrate her
she's been such a big influence in my
life you can tell on this record who is
you know you can just see it well
Arianna also on the record the other
baby your other baby what was it like to
work with her in this capacity I knew I
want to do I've always told her she
should visit Lesley gore and maybe play
her life story so I'm just putting it
out there I knew you don't know me seems
like us I don't like to refer to myself
as old school but I do think this song
is old school versus new school because
it's orchestrated and then I added
electric guitar I wanted to celebrate
Lesley gore and I thought who could I do
this with that's you know got that kind
of voice it's Ariana well I can't wait
to hear what that song sounds like are
you guys friends now like are you
texting with Ariana Grande yeah yes okay
what do you text with Ariana I tell man
it won't be special I just love her I'm
proud of her I'm no no she was a little
kid
her grandma brought her see wicked and
she said I would be a singer too I
thought oh well that's sweet and I ever
wand I said you'll do it you Bieber one
together why did she kept it she kept it
all this all these years yeah where does
she have this one I think it's at her
mom's house yeah I love her I feel like
you guys need to work together again in
some capacity doing something do you
guys talk about that like what could we
do like maybe on screen yeah I I really
really want a shepherd a project for her
I think it's important for people and
had lived like I have two shepherd are
young I do see her playing Lesley gore
I'm just saying
and she's got the voice and bad actors
and singer with robot and Ariana have
the acting chops as well so you can see
what I'm doing here I want these girls
to fly this is why this album is
important for the girls you know hey
what does this album I mean you've put
out so much music and your voice just
gets more and more angelic but what does
this really mean to you just really you
know I think about all the songs I've
wanted to sing and it looked at the
listener it's all my favorite singers
and some didn't make the cut which is
hard you know but we're having a
Renaissance women we're having a
resurgence and I want it to be for the
girls but I also want to say hey Dad you
know this is for the men who loved us
too because my dad was great is a great
influence on my life so you know I
wouldn't be where I am without him
without him saying you can do it you can
do it so yeah it's for the girls but
it's for the guys who love us do
now we're gonna ask about a little
homework movie coming out with Scott
wolf I am obsessed with all things
hallmark I was actually at the tcas and
I saw you perform there I love holic you
also sound amazing that night um what
was it like working with Scott well I
was the first day I was just staring in
him and maybe drooled and I said after I
get out with my drooling situation I'll
get over and he's like I put my pants on
just like you Casey and we just became
very close and just love him he's such a
good family guy and he loves his work
he's professional and fun my kind of guy
and I hope there's more for us I think
there will be when does it come out it
comes out around Thanksgiving and I also
wrote a title song for it with my friend
Shelley right so it's when it's called
when angels land and I can't wait for
people to hear it we're gonna get some
new music in that movie so much new
Kristen I'm so excited about it you've
done so much you've done TV you've done
movies you've done Broadway is there
anything else on your bucket list that
you would love to accomplish pretties
the guys that get all the money and now
women have you got to produce a project
with Dov and Ariana maybe yeah I think
so I think that's I think he just nailed
it you heard it here first ladies
[Music]
[Applause]